so let's look at a last example of
applying the well ordering principle
this time to something that we actually
care about a theorem that really does
require some the theorem is the
following famous formula for the sum of
a geometric saw for a geometric series
or a geometric sum so the numbers on the
left the powers of are starting at one
which is R to the 0 followed by R which
is R to the 1 followed by R squared up
through the nth power of r you add all
those numbers up and it turns out that
there's a nice simple fixed formula that
doesn't have those three dots in it that
tells you exactly what the value of that
sum is in the formula as you can read as
R to the n plus 1 minus 1 is the
numerator and R minus 1 is the
denominator and the claim is that this
identity holds for all non-negative
integers N and for all real numbers R
that aren't 1 because I don't want the
denominator to be 0 so how we gonna
prove this well I'm gonna prove it by
using the well ordering principle and
let's suppose that this identity didn't
hold for some non-negative integer n so
we apply the well ordering principle and
we'll let M be the smallest number n
where this equality fails it becomes an
inequality now what I know about M
immediately is that this equality if you
look at it when n is 0 the left-hand
side comes down that degenerates to just
R to the 0 or 1 the right-hand side if
you check it is r minus 1 over r minus 1
which is also 1 so equality holds when n
is 0 and that means that the least M for
which equality doesn't hold has to be
positive so what we know about the least
number where this equality fails is that
it's positive and that means in
particular since it's the least one word
fails if you go down 1 to n minus 1 the
Equality holds so we can assume that the
sum of the first
empowers of our starting at zero and
ending an arm to the N minus one is
equal to the formula where you plug in M
minus 1 for N and you get that formula
on the right which I'm not gonna read to
you well we can simplify it a little bit
if you look at the exponent R to the N
minus 1 plus 1 is after all just R to
the M so so repeating what I've got is
that the sum of those first powers of
our up to n minus 1 we can assume is
equal to the formula R to the M minus 1
divided by R minus 1 because M failed
and this was the number 1 less where it
had to succeed so now we take the
obvious strategy what I'm interested in
is properties of the sum of the powers
up to R to the M now the left hand side
is the powers up to R to the n minus 1
so there's an obvious strategy for
turning the left hand side into what I'm
interested in namely let's add our to
the M to both sides so the left hand
side becomes just the sum that I want
and the right hand side becomes this
messy thing R to the N minus 1 over R
minus 1 plus R to the M well let's just
simplify a little bit let's put our to
the M put it over the denominator R
minus 1 which I do by multiplying it by
R minus 1 and then it comes out to be R
to the n plus 1 minus R to the M over R
minus 1 and I collect terms and look
what I got
I've got the formula R to the n plus 1
minus 1 over R minus 1 which means that
the identity that I was originally
claiming in fact holds it M
contradicting the assertion that it
didn't hold it M in other words we've
reached a contradiction assuming there
was a least place where equality fails
that means there's no counter example
and the Equality holds for all
non-negative integers N
so here's the general organization of a
well ordering proof which we've been
using let's just sort of summarize it
into a kind of a template for proving
things so what you have in mind is that
there's some property P of n of
non-negative integers and what you'd
like to prove is that it holds for every
non-negative integer so for all and in
non-negative integers P of n holds and
we're gonna try to prove this by the
well ordering principle which means that
we're gonna define the set of numbers
for which P doesn't hold that is the set
of counter examples and call that C so C
is the set of non-negative integers for
which not P of n holds now by the well
ordering principle there's got to be a
minimum element call it M that's in C
and at this point the job by assuming
that M is the smallest counter example
we have to reach a contradiction somehow
now up to this second bullet
it's the template but the third bullet
is where the math real math starts and
there isn't any template anymore how you
reach a contradiction is by reasoning
about properties of P of n and there's
no simple recipe but the usual
organization of the contradiction is one
of two coins you find a counter example
that's smaller than M you find a C
that's in the set of counter examples
and C is less than M that would be a
contradiction because M be the smallest
thing and C or you reach a contradiction
by proving that P does hold for M which
means it's not a counter example and
those are kind of the two standard ways
to organize a well ordering proof